Hi, everyone.
Today, I'm going
to be talking
about Parkinson's
disease and its variants.
So the session objectives
include reviewing
the motor and non
-motor features of
Parkinson's, describing
the causes and
risk factors of
Parkinson's, comparing
symptoms that distinguish
idiopathic Parkinson's
from atypical
Parkinson's disease.
We're going to use
your knowledge in order
to make the diagnosis
of Parkinson's and
then apply appropriate
treatment options
to treat the disease,
and we're going to
review the adverse
effects of the drugs.
So in terms of the
history, James Parkinson
lived 1775 to 1874.
He was a medical
practitioner that lived
in England, and he
originally wrote an essay
on the shaking palsy.
And every year,
this collage of
people gets larger.
So these are
currently, and people
who are recently
deceased, who have
had Parkinson's.
Everyone from politicians
like Jesse Jackson,
Singers, Lisa Ronstadt,
Neil Diamond,
Ozzy Osbourne,
***** Lewis,
the actor recently
passed away,
Alan Alda, a couple
of sports figures,
Brett Favre just
announced that he had
Parkinson's, Brian
Grant was a basketball
player, of course,
Michael J. Fox,
Muhammad Ali.
and then Robin Williams
the comedian actually
had Lewy body dementia
Dudley Moore had
progressive supranuclear
palsy and the former
president George H
.W. Bush actually had
vascular Parkinsonism
so to review Parkinson's
the way that I like
to think of it is by
using words that start
with the letter S.
So some of them
include slow, stiff,
shake,
shuffle, stooped, and
slip, describe the gait,
slurred speech,
sedentary for the
lack of movement,
salaria is drooling,
seeing things include
hallucinations that
can occur later on
in the course of
disease, staring, which
is that they don't
blink. There are a lot
of sleeping issues.
They can have difficulty
with swallowing,
social isolation,
SAD due to the
depression,
and then ******
dysfunction.
In terms of the
pathology, there is
degeneration of the
nigrostriatal dopaminergic
pigmented neurons
that occur in the
ventral lateral region
of the substantia
*****, And this is
found in nearly all
patients with clinical
Parkinson's disease.
There are Lewy bodies
that are found with that.
The Lewy bodies are
found mostly in the
brainstem and they're
composed of alpha
-synuclein. And it's an
imbalance between the
direct and indirect
pathways of the basal
ganglia that leads to
the bradykinesia. Yeah.
Patients develop
symptoms when 60% of the
dopaminergic neurons
are already lost. And
there are various
clinical presentations.
Patients can present
young. They could
present with non-motor
symptoms. The disease
can move very quickly
or slowly. And the
picture that you see
there is representing
the fact that some
patients first will
develop a frozen
shoulder or just shoulder
pain that they think
is orthopedic as
their first presentation.
And very often the
diagnosis of Parkinson's
can be missed.
And so patients can
actually present
somewhere between 10
and 20 years prior to
any motor symptoms
with loss of smell.
They can also develop
constipation
or depression.
So here are some
other symptoms.
As I mentioned
before, stiffness,
including a frozen
shoulder, constipation,
change in voice,
loss of smell,
REM sleep behavior
disorder, and
then a watch that
stops moving.
These can all
represent early
symptoms of Parkinson's.
The watch is a watch
that you have to
wind every day if
you're not wearing
it, but if somebody's
arm doesn't swing,
then the watch can
stop on its own.
So some of the
environmental
risk factors
include pesticides,
rural living,
likely using
well water, heavy metals,
Agent Orange exposure,
such as in Vietnam,
drug use, including
MPTP, and head injuries.
And in 2020,
Parkinson experts,
Dr. Dorsey,
Scherer, Okun, and
Bloom wrote this
book, Ending
Parkinson's Disease.
And some of the things
that they proposed
is that 30% of the
United States drinking
water is contaminated
with trichloroethylene,
which can be a cause
of Parkinson's.
Paraquat has
been banned in 32
countries, but not in
the United States, and
actually can increase
the risk of developing
Parkinson's by
150%. Additionally,
chlorpyrifos, which
is a nerve toxin, is
the most widely used
insecticide in the U
.S., and it is used on
crops and in golf courses
and unfortunately
has not been banned.
So in terms of genetics,
most patients do
not have a genetic
component and therefore
it's a sporadic disease.
However, 10% are
found to have a gene.
So patients with GBA,
which is the
glucocerebrosidase, can have
a more rapid cognitive
decline, and the GBA
is seen most in
Ashkenazi Jews. The LARC2
is also an Ashkenazi
genetic component,
but it also has a slower
motor progression.
Parkin is an autosomal
recessive gene and
is relatively common
when Parkinson's develops
in the third or
fourth decade of life.
What's an interesting
thing to know is that
people who have the
GBA1 gene, which is the
gene mutation that
causes Gauches,
also have an
increased risk of
developing
Parkinson's disease.
They also have a
risk of developing
Lewy body dementia due to
the alpha-synuclein
accumulation.
So some people aren't
sure when to test
for the gene. And so
if someone develops
Parkinson's before
50 but doesn't have a
family history, it's
appropriate to test.
It would also be
appropriate if a
patient has a strong
family history or patients
come from an Ashkenazi
Jewish background
or North African
Berber background.
The seven most
common genes that are
frequently tested are
as follows, the SNCA,
PARKIN, PINK1,
PARK7, LARC2,
the VPS35, and
the GBA gene.
So reviewing the
classic motor symptoms,
we like to think
of TRAP, which
is tremor, rigidity,
and it could be
axial, which could
be in the neck or
in the arms, which
is appendicular,
akinesia or bradykinesia,
which simply is
slowness, and then
postural instability,
which is the
tendency to fall, and
it can also be
associated with freezing.
And freezing
doesn't mean that
their temperature
is cold. It means
they have difficulty
getting started.
So tremor is usually
the first motor
symptom, and it could
be, it's usually
asymmetric, but it
can be bilateral.
It's usually at
rest, but there
could be a
postural component.
A patient does not
need to have a tremor
to have Parkinson's,
and they also can
have a tremor and
not have Parkinson's.
The frequency of the
tremor is four to
six hertz. It's
generally pill rolling,
and a jaw tremor
can also be present.
Rigidity is essential
also for the
diagnosis of Parkinson's.
It's generally
seen more in the arms
than in the neck.
There can be
cogwheeling, excuse me,
and cogwheeling is a
stiffness or resistance
of the limb when it's
passively flexed.
Cogwheeling can also
indicate a tremor and
can be seen in essential
tremor as well.
Bradykinesia simply
means a slowness, and
it could be seen with
repetitive alternating
movements, so
meaning with finger
or foot tapping, the
movements get slower
as the patient
continues the movement.
There's loss of facial
expression that we
call masked faces.
There's generally
reduced arm swing. It
could be on one arm or
both arms. And then
sialorrhea or drooling
occurs due to
swallowing dysfunction.
In terms of gait, there's
reduced arm swing.
Festinating gait
is when the patient
walks and then has
difficulty slowing down.
There is something
called turning on block,
which means that it
takes them several
steps in order to make
a turn rather than
turning on a pivot.
They generally shuffle
their feet, and they
have stoop posture.
There's freezing,
which is the inability
to move it's often
occurs through doorways
and through crowds
they have difficulty
taking the first step
and it can be a very
common cause of falls
and as you could
see here there's
a list of different
non-motor symptoms
which include
neuropsychiatric,
cognitive,
autonomic or disautonomic,
and sleep disorders.
And patient could
have any combination
of these different
symptoms, which makes
them very challenging
to treat, especially
because non-motor
symptoms can be more
difficult to the patient
than motor symptoms.
Campocormia is what
you see here that when
the patient tries to
walk, they're completely
bent over. However,
you could lie them
completely flat. And this
is a truncal dystonia.
So as they walk, they
get more and more
bent over, but it is
not a fixed posture.
There are
neuropsychiatric symptoms
that often occur,
and it is due to a
complicated mix of
Parkinson's and other
neurodegenerative
disease pathology,
neurotransmitter
deficits,
neural circuitry
derangement,
and genetic
influences. They
suffer from
depression, anxiety,
cognitive impairment,
psychosis,
impulse control
disorders, and apathy.
The sleep disorders
include REM sleep
behavior disorder, which
means that the patients
act out their dreams
rather than being
relaxed during their
dreams. Very often,
they might hurt
themselves or their bed
partner, and so this
needs to be addressed.
Restless leg syndrome
is common, insomnia,
somnolence, excessive
daytime sleepiness.
They could have sleep
attacks, meaning that
during the day, either
while driving or
during a conversation,
they could simply fall
asleep, and then vivid
dreaming is common.
treating hallucinations
is a challenge
because generally when
treating hallucinations,
it targets dopamine
and can make a patient
floridly Parkinsonian.
The only drugs that
are safe to use in
hallucinations with
Parkinson's include
quetiapine or Seroquel,
clozapine, which is
also clozaril is the
brand name. However,
it can cause severe
neutropenia and needs
to have frequent
blood monitoring.
And then the only
FDA approved drug
for hallucinations is
called pimavanserin
or nuplacid. But
there's the issue that
it can prolong the
QT interval that one
must be aware of.
In terms of treating
dementia, the only
FDA-approved drug for
Parkinson's dementia
is rivastigmine, which
is a cholinesterase
inhibitor. Other
drugs that have
been looked at include
dilantamine and
denepazil and memantine.
And although they
can be used, they are
not used on label.
So when a patient
presents with Parkinsonian
symptoms, one has
to think of the
possible other things
that could be causing
it. So the differential
can include, these
are atypical Parkinsonian
syndromes such
as MSA or multiple
system atrophy, PSP,
which is progressive
supranuclear palsy,
cortical basal
degeneration,
dementia with
Lewy bodies,
drug-induced
Parkinsonism,
essential tremor,
normal pressure
hydrocephalus, and
vascular Parkinsonism.
So how do you know
if the patient has
atypical Parkinson's?
So these are some of
the red flags. Patient
presents with early
dementia with
hallucinations. In idiopathic
Parkinson's, they
shouldn't develop
dementia until much later
on in the condition.
It could be at least
10 years or more.
Symmetrical signs,
meaning they
present with
bilateral tremor,
bilateral stiffness.
In idiopathic
Parkinson's, it's
usually asymmetric.
Early gait disorder
with falls is also
typical for atypical
Parkinson's. Generally,
patients don't have
gait disorders and falls
until much later on
in the course of the
disease. Severe
orthostasis, where they
develop syncopal episodes,
is more likely to
happen in multiple
system atrophy. They can
develop alien limb,
which is when the hand
is doing its own thing
without the patient
really being aware
of it. Inspiratory
stridor and markedly
reduced eye movements.
So to review dementia
with fluey bodies,
this is a synucleinopathy.
It is common
to have REM sleep
behavior disorder.
Dementia is common
in the first
year of Parkinson's
symptoms. They
can develop visual
hallucinations,
fluctuate, fluctuating
cognition. They
will have a symmetric
tremor, Parkinsonism,
and Capgras syndrome.
And Capgras syndrome
is when they believe
that somebody has
replaced their spouse
or someone close
to them. They also have
exquisite medication
sensitivity. So any
medicine that you
give them, often they
do not agree with.
Progressive
supranuclear palsy is a
tauopathy. This is
Dudley Moore, who
was an author and
he developed PSP.
There is widespread
atrophy and
neuronal loss.
There is supranuclear
gaze palsy. They have
difficulty with their
eye movements. And so
if you move their head,
their eyes will move.
And those are the
doll's eyes. They can
have pseudobulbar palsy,
facial dystonia with
an angry look on their
face, growling speech.
They often will fall
backwards and have
difficulty with swallowing
and often aspirate,
which these can be
causes of their demise.
MSA or multiple system
atrophy can occur
with Parkinsonism or
with cerebellar ataxia.
It's an alpha
synucleinopathy and it can
occur with autonomic
insufficiency such
as urinary incontinence
or retention,
orthostasis that alternates
with hypertension,
anhydrosis and
impotence. They
could develop
cerebellar abnormalities
and commonly
laryngeal stridor.
So corticobasal
degeneration is fairly
uncommon, but needs to
be included here. It's
a hyperphosphorylated for
repeat tau inclusions.
It's generally
asymmetric with cortical
atrophy, especially
in the frontoparietal
region. It is markedly
asymmetric with
significant rigidity
on one side, and there
could be a dystonia.
there is a variable
levodopa response.
Generally there is no
resting tremor and they
can develop apraxia but
alien limb phenomenon
such as while they're
getting dressed one
hand could be buttoning
and the other hand
may be unbuttoning.
Normal pressure
hydrocephalus needs to be
excluded because this
could be a treatable
form of Parkinson's and
the classic triad is
the wet Wacky and
Wobbly, which stands for
urinary incontinence,
dementia, and gait
disturbance. They
generally have a magnetic
gait, which is slow
and wide-based. It's
routine to do a high
volume lumbar puncture,
check the opening
pressure, which would be
normal. And if the patient
improves, then they
will have a ventricular
peritoneal shunt
to drain the excess
cerebral spinal fluid.
So once a patient has
symptoms and you've
examined them, how do
you determine which
condition they have?
So of these tests,
what would be
appropriate? Head CT, MRI,
DAT,
PET, lumbar puncture,
skin biopsy. So
head CT and MRI are
not helpful except that
they can exclude
things like strokes,
multiple sclerosis,
brain tumors. A
DAT scan can help.
A PET scan generally
is no longer
performed because
they're hard to get.
A lumbar puncture and
a skim biopsy are now
newer modalities to make
a diagnosis. However,
it still remains a
clinical diagnosis.
In terms of a DAT
scan, this is the
dopamine transporter
single photon
emission CT and it
uses ioflupane I
-23 injection and
visualizes dopamine
on nerve terminals
in the striatum.
This condition can
help differentiate
Parkinson's from
essential tremor. As you
can see, the image
on the left is a
normal scan and the
image on the right is
abnormal. And this is
more of a functional
scan rather than
a still picture.
It shows the activity
of the dopamine.
Alpha-synuclein
testing is newer.
It could be done in
Parkinson's, MSA and
Lewy body dementia,
including and pure
autonomic failure,
which are all
synucleinopathies. All
of these conditions have
accumulations of
phosphorylated alpha
-synuclein aggregates.
They can be found
in the central and
peripheral nervous
systems. So now
there've been biomarkers
that you can look
for either in
the CSF or with
a punch biopsy
to check cutaneous
nerve fibers.
And these are
newer, although
they're not
routinely done.
Again, this is still
a clinical diagnosis,
but alpha-synuclein
testing can
be done in these
conditions.
PET scan reveals
reduced uptake of
fluoridopa and the
dopaminergic nerve
terminals, this test
is not as readily
available to look
for Parkinson's.
In terms of the
treatment options,
levodopa is still the
mainstay of treatment.
However, patients
still can receive
MEOI inhibitors,
dopamine agonists,
COMT inhibitors,
amantadine,
and anticholinergics.
So carbidopa, levodopa,
again, this is
the gold standard.
Levodopa is given
with carbidopa, which
prevents the peripheral
breakdown of levodopa
in the periphery. It
also decreases the
nausea side effect. The
levodopa, after it's
absorbed, it crosses
the blood-brain
barrier, and then it
becomes dopamine. It is
available immediate
and extended release.
Rytari and Crexont
are both immediate
and extended release
formulations. Crexont
was just approved
in October of 2024.
On the right side of
the screen, you could
see an image of imbresia,
which is the first
inhaled levodopa. And
then there's an image
of the intestinal gel,
which is the DUOPA,
and that requires a
surgery to the duodenum.
The bottom pill
is the original
yellow carbidopa
levodopa cinemath.
Monoenoxidase inhibitors,
they're all MAOIB, not A.
Seleguline, risaguline,
and safinamide.
Safinamide is only
given as add-on
for patients already
taking carbidopa
levodopa and having
off episodes.
Seleguline and
risaguline can be given
independently of
taking anything else,
although not very
effective and it's now been
disproven, they are
no longer considered
neuroprotective. um
serotonin syndrome
can only happen with
type a um not mao b
the type a breaks down
serotonin or epinephrine
whereas type b
breaks down dopamine
the dopamine agonists
directly stimulate
dopamine receptors they
have two oral forms
which is the premapaxil
or mirapax and ropinarol,
which is requip.
There's the subcutaneous
injection, apomorphine
or apocaine, and
the patch is the
rotigotine patch or nupro.
And the problem with
the dopamine agonists
are the adverse effects.
They can develop
sleep attacks, meaning
that they could fall
asleep while they're
driving. They could develop
ankle and leg edema,
impulse control
disorder, including
hypersexuality and gambling,
confusion, and
generally they develop
less dyskinesias than
levodopa. I've had
patients that have had
difficulty in terms
of becoming addicted
to social media,
spending money, and
going to strip clubs.
Gambling has
also been a big
problem for
many patients.
So COMT inhibitors
include intacopone,
tolcopone, which now
is no longer being
used because of
hepatic necrosis, and
then the newest
opicopone or ungentis is
an extended release
COMT inhibitor. These
medications are
used to reduce the
breakdown of levodopa
and increase on time.
And the side effect
of these drugs is that
it turns the urine
dark, so patients
need to be warned
about this side effect.
It does not occur
with the long
-acting COMT,
the opigapone,
but does occur
with intacapone.
and some miscellaneous
drugs, trihexafenadil
is an anticholinergic
drug and it's
very good for tremor
but can also cause
earlier confusion or
cognitive problems.
Benztropine is also
anticholinergic.
Amantadine, an extended
release amantadine,
which is gocovery,
is an NMDA antagonist
with mild indirect
dopaminergic properties.
The adverse effect
of the amantadine
is levito
reticularis, which is
the lacy rash
seen to the right.
The long-acting
amantadine gokovery
actually improves
on time and both can
reduce levodopa
-induced dyskinesias.
is a newer mechanism
of action in adenosine
a2a receptor blocker
which can be used
as add-on therapy also
to reduce off periods
of motor symptoms
deep brain stimulation
is has now been around
for over 20 years.
It's not for everyone
and is not an
option just because
a patient has had
it long-term. If a
patient has atypical
Parkinsonism,
unstable psychiatric
disease, advanced
dementia, or other comorbid
medical conditions,
they may not be a
candidate for surgery.
However, if done properly,
this could be a
very good option for
patients with idiopathic
Parkinson's who don't
have any of the above
exclusionary criteria.
MRI guided focused
ultrasound can
also be used for
Parkinson tremor
and dyskinesia,
but to date,
it's generally
unilateral therapy only.
It's also contraindicated
in patients
with severe cognitive
impairment. A patient
must be able to
tolerate an MRI, and
after having the lesion,
it's irreversible
and cannot be adjusted
post-procedure.
And then of course,
last but not least,
exercise is the most
important treatment for
Parkinson's. It is the
only thing that we know
about that can prevent
the progression of
this disease. And as I
tell my patients, the
medicine is for today,
the Parkinson's is for
tomorrow. The medicine
does not slow the
disease, it helps the
patients get to the gym.
And rock-steady
boxing has been
incredibly
effective because it
improves compliance
in the patients.
In terms of OMT,
trials are underway,
but can improve both
motor and non-motor
symptoms. It can
help with balance,
gait, and postural
stability, can help
with some of the
autonomic dysfunction,
the posture, breathing,
and much more.
There have been case
reports that Parkinson's
have developed
after COVID-19, so
there's still a lot
of work going on to
see if there's really
a connection between
the virus and
Parkinson's. Parkinson's.
And here is a review
of the idiopathic
and atypical forms
of Parkinson's and
some key things to
remember for each one.
And so in summary,
hopefully in the
future, you'll
recognize Parkinson's,
recognize the
red flags, not
Parkinson's, but
something close to it.
Hopefully you
understand how to
make the diagnosis
and be familiar
with the
treatment options.
Thank you very
much. That concludes
this presentation,
and my email
is below if you
have any questions.
Thank you.